in hospital
I have been intolerant bro I'm a man
studying up there
[Music]
welcome
um episode
293 I presume 293
um it is episode 293 we are seven
episodes away from our wholesome uh
three bills three billy 300 episodes and
um yeah that's a that's a fantastic
Milestone I'm not gonna lie to you it's
a fantastic Milestone almost soon come
soon come we're nearly there but we go
straight into it as per as you already
know IG question and the IG question of
the week was
something you saw in someone or that
they did that made you think damn no
wonder you're single
well something someone did or that you
saw in their personality in general yeah
they think okay cool this is why you're
single no wonder you're single
is so mad as well that like I know this
is super prevalent in I'm just gonna say
it's super prevalent in women is that
like being single is perceived to be a
negative of one a negative and for two
not someone's choice
um this whole like damn no wonder you're
single which is basically translates to
you can't get anyone to anyone yeah
because no one will choose this life you
know what I mean no one would choose to
be single so you clearly just can't get
someone and this is why this is why I'ma
read em up bro all right yeah men and
women doing saying the most all right
say that sell us they have their profile
pic as a selfie from the chin up
one of these ones who that's disgusting
yeah
Peak this girl said come for me pretty
boy whilst giving me top
oh what do you mean no wonder she's
single
I can hear that pretty boy
I don't know about all the da yeah but I
don't even hear by the time you said
come for me yeah yeah I don't hear the
rest especially if I'm like a few
Strokes away yeah yeah I don't hear the
pretty boy stuff yeah yeah even if I did
call me what you want when I'm not close
just when I'm not close call me what you
want call me a donkey I don't care I
don't care bro once you set those three
magic words come for me yeah it's
everything bro yeah yeah
my ears like ringing bro don't be a
slave I don't care
I was waiting for the land
[Laughter]
you need to care bro bro you need to
promise you I wouldn't care you need to
care I know I need to but
it reminds me we'll talk about it but it
reminds me of an episode of the show
we're going to talk about later okay
yeah come
um ah yeah
[Music]
bro
sorry guys for screaming we'll get we'll
get into it soon
what's something you saw in someone or
that they did that made you think damn
no wonder they're single
they ran a Twitter porn account and
shouted out porn stars daily
okay cool oh wow okay so they're just
not even it wasn't even account for them
no bro it was just shedding light on the
industry and like they're a fan yeah
they ran the account they were just
adding just at important that's crazy
that's a lot man I don't understand
people who go to like the conventions
yeah like a comments yeah like a comic
concept yeah yeah yeah and they just
want to just go like meet the celebs
yeah it's the meet and greets are just
that's weird yeah because I've like
bashed to you and to do up hugs in
photos like no that's not the fantasy
I'm looking yeah bro I heard that um I
Heard what's her name man Gianna
Michaels no it wasn't Gianna Michaels
Sarah J no it wasn't let me keep you
guys let me hear something Ava Divine no
am I close
but I don't know what's close bro you
were saying yeah you're close with
gender like whatever like what race is
she white short brown hair Francesca
James no no no no no no I was the same
name oh I read it buddy rotten no no no
no it's uh Adrian uh yeah yeah she's the
goat
[Music]
she was saying she was on a podcast a
little while ago saying that She Bangs
fans oh swear bangs fans Bros swear yeah
just like on a like a Make-a-Wish thing
just like
she just gives back and she She Bangs
fans bro gives back back
yeah she was saying that um dead man
when she does it it's like they bang her
better then I bet anyone else because
it's not stupid this is like their face
this is their dream yeah so if I'm going
to a porn thing I'm going to clap yeah
I'm going to live my fantasies
pictures you know no I want to know what
we can do that's all I want to know what
can we do facts yeah that's what I'm
here for man am I here to chit chat she
gives back
whoa a lot of jokes she shot herself
twice in a month at work she wasn't
single but he did cheat on her
God
oh he did to you wow she celebrated
Mother's Day she didn't have kids just
dogs
okay yeah that's that's taking it too
far I'm gonna this is I'm sorry this is
targeting someone in this room I can't
deal with the mummy and daddy for animal
stuff bro I can't deal with it Grandma
I'm just gonna say it I can't deal with
it bro what are you on about bro when
I'm I can't deal with someone being a
dog mommy or daddy or a dog a kid a cat
daddy or Mommy I have a cat I have two
cats yeah but yeah you have a cat but
like if you identify as their daddy I
don't identify as a daddy I didn't even
want them they got bought into my yard
they now live here with me Fair bro I'm
just saying I can't handle it when
people do that let's say any kids now
but I've got a cat oh now but I've got
two dogs
no it's a different conversation bro
crazy when I hate people say that kind
of stuff you've never told me that by
the way you've never said that well I've
never asked you if you've got any
[__] kids
when people say yeah I know you're not
the kind of person if someone said any
kids and you were like nah but I've got
cats right that's not stuff to me yeah I
do love my cats though I'm aware you do
it and the defensiveness is leaning into
what everything what everything all
right it's reimbursing everything that I
brought
you are the toxic one
that's a joke oh but yeah all right cool
let's go my sister-in-law ate tartar
sauce straight out the packet because
she was too hungry to wait for food okay
that's terrifying tartar sauce
I don't even know if I've ever had
tartar sauce yeah I've never had I don't
eat fish
uh I ate fish and fishes like battered
Cod and what else it probably haddock
and stuff yeah it's buff yeah when I now
when I go chip shop I get sausage oh say
less pause pause
her forehead was so big she could smoke
a cigarette in the rain
[Laughter]
wow no wow I've never heard of that
before
what a dig bro yeah yeah
[Laughter]
whoa what a dig bro not playing games
wow
if someone grilled me like that yeah bro
your forehead's so big you can smoke a
cigarette in the rain
there is no comeback but it's just yeah
it is consisticuffs there is no comeback
there isn't because the whole crowd is
shutting down yeah they're erupt yeah
they're erupting
you'll be screaming on the mic they
won't be able to hear you yeah you're
trying to defend yourself nah bro the
crowd is going nuts everybody from the
3-1-3 that's all there
wow oh God she threw herself down the
stairs during an argument
that's crazy
don't tell me someone no I've never seen
someone throw themselves down the stairs
are they threatened to but I've seen one
of my boys arguing this is he's not my
boy to be fair let's not claim him but
he was a bridge when I was like 17 18.
okay and I remember one time he was
arguing with his girl yeah he was
arguing with his girl
and he got so livid no his arguing with
his girl and his girl's sister pulled up
in the whip so this was in the middle of
the night we're in the middle of a
street yeah and I'm like leave it bro
come on come on let's go so it's you the
best girl the Brar his girl and then
half an hour into this on Street ordeal
yeah her sister pulled up yeah to pick
her up Sister jumped out the car yeah
and was running her mouth he got so
living he was trying to walk off the
system was chasing him down like just
aggravating him so he turned around she
was like let's say he stood here
the her car is here and the sister's
like over there
he was just like [__] leave me alone
yeah Rock the wing mirror off the car
yeah it skirted pasta she fell to the
floor She was like you assaulted me oh
she bailed the feds no she bailed the
fans I dipped all right he spent the
night in jail I did I was like I'm not
I'm not listening to this because she
was white as white as well I was like
this isn't going to end well I ran down
the closest alley I could find oh my God
then he bailed me from pen No did he get
that uh if you want to answer this call
but how does it even work
is that just America I think it is just
it didn't I didn't get that no so it was
from pen and he just said hello and he
said well gone like Juan G and he said
you'll never believe where I am I said I
I bet you I can I can guarantee it I
know exactly where you are I know
exactly where you want to come up what
number came up
um I'm not gonna lie to you I don't
remember this was like
16 years ago
um so yeah I don't I don't really
remember it's not that many it's like 14
or 12 years ago but yeah um yeah say
same same bro
um yeah I don't remember anything about
that I was remembering calling me from
Pence then you'll never believe where
where I am and he woke me up as well oh
you won't believe where I am I said
brother I know exactly where you are
you're in jail bro because she didn't
run with me yeah yeah she she screamed
assault in the street oh mad at 11
o'clock at night
yeah why are you hanging around that's
fast for what for what and he's walking
away as well and he was yeah he was
walking away so yeah yeah yeah she was
she was that type she was that stairs
type damn yeah it was not damn all right
I've got more than a few she was talking
about our future relationship and
businesses within the first 24 hours we
met at a club
that's such essential information we met
our club yeah Club bro she's doing up
let's let's we can do we can make
businesses chill I just I'm here for a
good time bro facts that most definitely
not a long time not a long time just a
great time
ah great
I'm drunk bro drunk and I'm oh yeah no
yeah you know what I want no one this is
like Club yeah shot with your business
and future relationship I'm entertaining
it for now because I need some yeah but
zip it
I'm not gonna tell you again zip it
oh she cries when she watches Britain's
Got Talent
that's some embarrassing but some people
do
oh God
my stepmom gets infested with Strictly
Come Dancing and it it makes my blood
the nation do to be fair they should
love strictly she gets invested bro
doesn't make sense to the point where
it's like I'm not leaving the yard
rolled it's strictly
I get so angry strictly seasoned I get
angry bro it's it baffles me bro
[__]
anyway yeah go on Strictly you know a
woman bringing her own block of cheese
and grater to the restaurant every
single time that's impossible
I promise it's impossible it has to be
impossible every single time that has to
be a grater and cheese a block of our
own cheese for different Cuisines
um Indian Italian
whatever she wants bro Chinese Max
cheese clearly bro some people did you
ever used to watch there's a show
there's a show called like fussy eaters
or something back a day did you used to
watch that would like you'd put like bro
it was where people go to like um people
had eaten disorders bro and literally
there'd be some people in there could
that would only eat cheese
I've seen one yet on there she would
only eat cheese bro and these man was so
extra yeah like the Doctor Who would
come over to the yard to try and like
change their diet it put like a plate of
broccoli in front of them and it's faint
oh there's some other broccoli it's like
gagging yeah oh I've seen one where she
smelled like a Brussels sprout yeah
she was
um
yeah they used to get me started they're
so pathetic it's so perfect they're
proudly you should put her hands on the
sink
that was my wife I was shove it in her
mouth
[__] eater
you need it bro you stink
Bros cheese facts
bro there's Channel 4 used to channel 4
used to make TV yeah they put what they
want on there and it's the embarrassing
bodies
um but to be fair they still do because
they run naked attractions Sun sex and
suspicious parents well son was that
channel four I'm pretty sure no no no
that was BBC
um BBC three three
yeah sunsets and suspicious parents bro
wow for you like that don't know about
yeah
suspicious parents was a show where
um a production company would get in
contact with stupid teenagers who had
just turned 18 yeah and they want to
rock out with a [__] out bro and I
before
course
Cyprus Tenney anyway all them places
all them Butters Club places
um they would pay for their trip out
there and be like we're doing some doing
up some like singles uh like coming of a
experiment experiment show away from
yard away from yard for the first time
um living it up and obviously the idiots
were like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah run
me the money put me on a plane ticket
I'm gonna go ham dip let me get a tan
let me get a tan bro and then they would
the behind the scenes they would fly
their parents out there to watch what
their kids were on bro they'd go through
their luggage
see what they're doing see if their lips
and anyone will come and fight they'll
um showcase maybe on the last day the
last day that they'd pull up and the
amount of times the moms wanting to bust
out of this back door yeah to surprise
the kids bro because they couldn't
handle whatever is going on yeah because
yeah the couple man's daughters were
getting clapped in this show yeah it was
Peak a couple months doors were getting
ran through on this show and the dad
couldn't handle it anymore
his little baby girl
they will build them bro they were
building we've just been cheating
she's getting awesome bro I couldn't see
that oh what my daughter getting run
through an ibifa no the whole production
thing is getting shot down
the whole thing's getting shut down I
don't care what I'm saying yeah I don't
care what I've signed bro take me to
call what's my daughter were talking
about you can't publish this yeah not
myself you call it you can't let the
world see this stuff I would run a pin
there bro the markers bro mid clap I
don't care
I'm running up in there no no no no
everyone's jumping off Balcones
bro all right I've got a few more uh
what's something you saw in someone or
did that they did that made you think no
wonder they're single she's a compulsive
liar so much so that she's pregnant and
her parents thinks she's just gaining
weight
whoa yeah that's compulsive but how long
for how long how are you gonna get away
with that do you know what I mean
especially if you live your parents fam
I know a brother I'm convinced this
[__] was lying I went to school with a
brother yeah
who was going out with one sturdy thing
yeah and
allegedly yeah she didn't know she was
pregnant until she started having
contractions wow
allegedly these men didn't know she was
pregnant until she was pushing that's
crazy
you can't announce that to me in that
day oh no no I would fall down bro you
can't announce that to me that day I
actually don't know what I would do I
would don't I wouldn't believe you of
course not of course not it's not mine
because you ain't bled in like a year
Piper yes fast speak up box
Fox speak yes something's wrong so let
us know yeah wow your boobs have been
sore for a minute yeah why speak up say
something you just been puking in the
mornings bro say something how are you
how do you not know you're pregnant just
how so many signs along the way you've
you felt bad in your stomach and you're
just like oh indigestion indigestion or
I'm hungry yeah
my stomach's doing a Madness mad mad
working out there working out their part
of the bill to the penny
oh that's that's disgusting okay yeah
yeah one million percent that's a this
is why your single moment God to the
penny in a penny
I saw her dance confident Brazen offbeat
and ugly never seen a nine drop to a
five so quick oh
oh I'm going it from um
I don't even know her name I think we
saw her the other day from Manny I don't
know who I'm talking about I don't know
you're talking about that there's a link
thing
[Applause]
and not being able to dance is a crime
yeah it's
it's uh cross path that should never
happen
ever
yeah facts about it if I ever happened
if I was Kim Jong-un I'd Lop off your
hand for stuff like that
but you can't move to the beat you're
lame bro and I'm pretty new thinking bar
and you're doing like you know them
headsets
these things oh my how can you not move
to the beat bro and then just do like Oh
my days
it's so disgusting yeah it's Peak it's
so Peak I remember you remember catching
wines as a teenager and then she just
can't move she can't move and you're
trying to catch her wine yeah yeah
you're trying to also catch the Beats
wine bro and it's just yeah it makes you
look like you can't dance facts and I'm
like oh it's not even me bro it's her it
is her and you're trying to hold the
weight yeah yeah let me control this let
me lead let me leave follow me yeah
she's just coming all over the place bro
yeah yeah
it's been there bro
all right a few more
my boy try my boy tried to shout out bus
wanker out the car and he started
Peak
yo
oh oh torment he's still he's still
obsessed with WWE Peak yeah shameful he
has a lisp Peak that's that's
unfortunate that is unfortunate but
looks more teeth
my brother has my brother has fake
fights in the shower and in front of the
mirror oh raw Peak she's when I was a
you I had to try and catch the drops did
you ever try to do that
when something was like slow dripping I
used to go in there like
I used to pull up my River guard and if
it was like
I'm talking about when I was like eight
I'll be in the shower ass naked bro just
slapping
bro some of the things are killing me
bro my little naked asses
[Laughter]
oh that's hilarious
oh Jesus I said my little dick
[Laughter]
so funny I was in there just naked and
you know when you can hear the feet and
you know when the feet skids on the
bottom girl that's all you can do just
wet slaps
if I ever yeah how do you say catch it
and expect to see a drop in my head
yo oh God that's so funny James oh okay
wow that was so funny bro oh a few more
she used to spit so she used to she used
her spit to lay her edges whenever they
came out of place the skip Oh wrong
that's what he wrote The Stick yeah he's
a 36 year old man and living with his
mum in a bedroom that has no front door
then ones where mum says keep the door
open in fact it's permanently when
you've got hoes in here keep that door
open if I'm taking off his hinges
I've been single for five years and they
came to me for a relationship advice
last but not least God she allowed next
man to film himself what she allowed
next man to film himself
sucking her tea at a party
yeah I must say can I get hang on I'm
not even gonna say it again
I'm actually not even gonna say it again
because I don't even want the
reassurance
yeah no I'm done with that one I'm gonna
I'm gonna revert back to the door off
the hinge as well yeah because that was
stupid
um
I remember yeah I remember my mum
threatened to take my door off my hinges
really yeah because when I was like 16 I
just had [__] in my room I didn't know
what to do with it oh I always went for
a little phase in it ah like your boy
had a mustache now yeah yeah it's not
stifferent yeah stuff's different yeah
I'm grown I've got a mustache I know how
to use deodorant and I'm just different
now so I must have like three things on
rotation yeah yeah and they were just
friends yeah
[Applause]
obviously I close the door obviously
my mom didn't even knock bro open the
door said James
they come here my mom used to love to do
this thing she'll just say my name bro
say my name bro she'll open the door you
won't even see her you just see the door
open she's not even in the doorway and
then you'll hear her say James
from her room oh yeah James
all right
yeah
nothing that typical mum call yes come
over yeah yeah silence
yeah
yeah you have to go to the rear yeah bro
my mom did I ordered yes Mom what's up
keep that door open now of course I keep
that door open why am I right keep the
door open
James this is my house keep that door
open listen to me my mom's speaking to
me soft voice and she says brother
listen to me
just keep the door open yeah I'm like
all right so obviously
put the door like
yeah this one next day I had a new thing
it wasn't even the next day I was
talking about the next week new thing
over same thing in there Door Creek yeah
solar heard was a little slap and it
swung open oh my God I said say less
yeah and obviously I'm trying to talk to
home girl what's that she's like what's
that yeah yeah yeah
I'm a business guy I've got open door
policy in the house you know what I mean
and it show something your mom's gonna
come in no one's coming in man this is
my room fam I'll close the door I must
have closed the door because I was
thinking I have to get freaky with this
thing yeah yeah I'm 16. yeah yeah I've
got no choice and it sucks and she ready
to free it up I'm willing to piss off my
mom at this point I'm willing to do it
takes bro yeah to get my fingers in
there yeah I felt nice yeah I'm dying
bro yeah close that door sharp Brad she
said don't let one of these can't
remember what she said she called them
like fast go cells or Tarts or Saturn
I think she said talk she said don't let
one of these thoughts in his house again
while she was there yeah she called me
downstairs she hit me with another James
okay and she said you're taking a piss I
told you keep that door open don't let
one of these Tarts in his house again
coming up in here with his short skirts
bro
chure man oh well they're friends
house man why do I have been
inhospitable
I have been intolerant bro I'm a man
studying up there [__]
from that day on I could never have
another
I could never ever ever have another
thing in my house bro I don't think I
ever brought things around you
especially you
not when my parents were in anyway I'd
always do things when my parents were
away I mean
um my mom used to go on weekend trips
yeah that's one that's when [__] went
off mom went to night quite a bit pops
is a nice quite a bit my sister was in
in uni or college so so you had a yard
yard yeah there were times where I had
the yard to full length to myself for
like a couple weeks I remember
there was a time during I remember it
was
I think either yet it could have been
year 11 after an exam I was like I think
it could have been the our last season
maybe of the Year 10 year or the 11 year
I can't remember
um but I finished later than all my
other boys I'll give one of my um gave
one of my boys my key to my yard with
one of my close friends at the time
um get the party started oh take
everyone to get the Play Store
guys
use your common sense yes it's not it's
not his yard and it's one of them ones
where I didn't want to go overboard with
Amanda that I didn't know a fact um so I
remember I was going back got back to
the yard now
I said oh yeah there's a couple guys
that I know you know Timmy you know this
guy you know this guy but they got some
other people I was like I'm thinking
about the ratio
think about this and think about that
I'm like cool say less we're bringing
through anyway because it's Vibes it's
Vibes we were chilling chilling remember
this so post Play-Doh batty story yeah
yeah yeah so play the bass Play-Doh
battery as well as my ex that dumps
in the yard at the same time but this
was like after all that happened yeah so
we were all cool friends or whatever
um and I remember
yeah I remember
I'm I'm gonna be so confused as to which
one I wanted I bet because I was I was
looking at one and squeezing another
yeah and it was just like she is I knew
you when you were young and I know for a
fact that's what you were doing yeah I
was looking at one and squeezing another
I couldn't you know the ones when you're
hugging a thing and you're squeezing
their body yeah
knocking eyes with someone else yeah
you're pretending it's her dad
oh yeah yeah
but the Play-Doh battery left towards
the end and I think I got freaky with
the X at the time or we could I can't
remember which one it was one of them we
didn't bang but we we got hands yeah
yeah we got handsy but yeah man oh I
always did things literally a minute
three yard not when never when um yeah
my mom my stepdad used to go on like
these weekend trips they'd leave on like
a Thursday night and they come back like
Monday oh nice parties went off nice
week and then there was yeah there was
one occasion
this was when I went through that phase
where Johnny's weren't fitting me and
people weren't telling me how to use it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I was
panicking I didn't use a Johnny for like
my first six times I didn't use a Johnny
probably till now no no I didn't use the
Johnny probably till like first year at
Uni swear probably yeah I didn't use a
Johnny uh for time bro and uh yeah I had
things up in my head there must have
been like it was me and maybe three of
my boys and there was
equal amount this is on the Friday this
is what it was so we all had things yeah
it was four man four things yeah linked
up okay one of my boys in my mom's room
one of my boys and I hope Mama doesn't
hear this by the way one of my boys my
mom's yeah I changed all the shoes I
cleaned everything yeah he didn't even
clap okay he just slept in there with
one thing didn't do nothing I was living
because she was banging I would have
taken my mom's room out of everything
no because I out of us out of respect I
wasn't thinking about that I was trying
to be a good host oh you're fair so I I
didn't even take my room oh I took the
attic room was cold I slept on like a
sleeping bag oh yeah because I just
wanted everyone to be patterned up yeah
yeah so I gave one of my boys my mom's
room one of my boys my brother's room
yeah one of the boys in my room and I
took the attic yeah
um yeah so I'm trying to I'm trying to
do a thing upstairs on my thing Johnny
is not working I'm thinking raw I'm
nervous she's like what's wrong what's
wrong what's wrong don't pressure me
that's wrong what's wrong what's wrong
my dick was like yeah
oh
man that's literally what was going on
bro oh God man it wasn't
going down but I was like oh God I'm
nervous I'm nervous nervous yeah yeah
went in down I went downstairs to try
and just recuperate yeah yeah yeah I
thought my boy was I thought all my boys
were just nervous like me so I went into
my room my boy was clapping chicks in
there I was jealous and scared because
I've never seen anything like it facts
this is really real I felt like a kid
like scared
scared of their roughhousing in there I
was like whoa whoa
that's how I felt the first time I got
ahead so I continue
bro they were fully gone right now I
said bro bro [__] because I don't think
I was ready to do that upset
I didn't figure out my next steps
because I was thinking why even if the
journey was fit I don't know if I was
ready for that
whoa whoa whoa whoa so anyway I went up
since my sleep I told this girl sorry I
went to sleep bro
but then the next day speaking of this
ratio thing the next day
our Galley we're going so basically the
galley we were paired up with or all
from a different school they're all from
a different school so the next day I
patterned it so that I told Diesel from
the different School my mum gets home
tomorrow yeah that's why all you man are
here tonight Mama gets home tomorrow
when on the Saturday I plan to party it
was still the same for a man yeah like
eight or nine gal from our school okay
so I was patent okay I was like gang
setting up setting up and I we had two
we had two extra brethrens
um guys who were like they were in the
unit but they were also their own kind
of pair okay so they were kind of
wishy-washy with the unit yeah
troublemakers immature troublemakers so
I went bad their names on here but I
told my boy who's like closest to them
yeah so do not [__] invite them do
not tell them that nothing's going on
bro because they're gonna [__] up the
whole vibe they don't when they see
gallon oh man and
brother don't have to act bro like don't
bring them around this yard you spent
the whole day patterning drink yeah
patterning music patterning everything
everyone's gas like
yeah bro before anyone arrived I must
have been airing out the yard yeah for a
breeze in the yard open all the windows
because it was summer for I wanted to be
fresh yeah I want everyone to rock up in
here fresh yeah open my window look down
my street these two [__] were walking
on my street no someone
get out the shrubs bro and I was like
you're winding me up bro did I see you
when you opened the doors no no no no no
they didn't see as soon as I slammed the
door yeah pulled up to my boy and said
you you [__] invited a minute you
[__] invited me it's like no I didn't
invite it it's just because they were
asking me about it I was like no they
won't ask you about a flight they didn't
know about oh facts he was like no
because if they asked me what am I doing
this weekend
I said I was like they did not ask you
what you're doing this weekend we're 15
we don't do [__] yeah we don't do [__]
unless there's a lessons if we're not
doing nothing on a weekend so you're a
liar bro you better and they don't even
know my address so you told them my
address as well
damn needless to say they did exactly
what I thought they were going to do
they've messed up the whole vibe they
broke my brother's door
they broke my brother's door off his
hinges bro they brought my brother's
door I'm never talking about off the
hinges bro they broke my brother's door
off the hinge this is what made me think
about the whole Hindus thing so I was
doing a Long play yeah I was doing a
long story yeah they broke my brother's
door if it's hinges bro I was live it
damn livid alienated order gal trying to
hold wines trying to grips batty
non-solicited deals destroyed the whole
thing was chalked had to charge the
whole weekend how the hell did they
break the door they're [__] around
bro just ramping and [__]
oh they ruined the whole thing how did
it happen when your mum came back
I had to put it back on its hinges okay
but I slightly moved up because
obviously the the screw holes were
murdered yeah so I had to lift the door
up slightly do new holes and then like
the latch would cover the old holes
there was like half of one dodgy Hollow
bottom paying attention to stuff like
that yeah she got to figure that out for
like a year yeah yeah and then there's
no way you can blame me there's two lane
yes way too late don't you dare blame me
yeah you're a fact I don't know what
happened it's not even my door yeah look
at my brother facts yeah yeah don't look
at me I never had another party again
after that a white bear worst experience
of my life I've never had excitement go
so so high and drop so so low damn yeah
I was so upset to this day it burns me I
bet bro
livid anyway guys welcome back welcome
to the show welcome to the show sng 293
you're here with your boys J Money And
Fire Lord flags and uh before we go any
further guys you know what you need to
do head on over to patreon.com
four slash shits and gigs right now
donate a humble three pound a month 10
pedo run the Peter SMG and you're going
to unlock over three years of content
standard three years of content
where your boys came up we came down
we've laughed we've cried we've been
drunk we've been the whole shebang
um over on patreon and the best part
about it is it invests yourself in the
community SMG cult babies are over there
chatting away on the Discord chatting
away in the comments chirpsing here
parties there and uh it's all going off
over there and once a month we're going
to tune in with you guys on a humble
Zoom call we just had one last week it
was awesome it was insane some of the
stories in that one some of the stories
some of the questions everything
questions stories yeah it was it was it
was an emotional roller coaster the
other week um that was probably the best
one I've done yeah and I've said that
for the last three months
um so yeah head on over there guys
patreon.com shits and gigs and
indoctrinate yourself into the cult for
real for real guys we're closing on the
middle I'm not gonna lie to you we are
and Millie's creeping up we've exceeded
the 800k mark and we're we're going
forward guys so please subscribe to the
channel right now press the red button
when we said this on last week's episode
I was going through the comments on one
Brandon comment was like I'm not gonna
lie I didn't even know I wasn't
subscribed I swear I was just paying
attention to the message yeah yeah I
didn't even know I wasn't subscribed so
I'm subscribing now so if that's you
again now yeah press the button press
the actual button
rush out press the button yes the
goddamn book yeah bro yeah facts press
the goddamn blood
um so yeah press the button subscribe to
the channel let's get that wholesome
gold plaque that's really going to do
wonders for our skin our Aura and just
our attitude because like we need to
feel like we're legit in this game and
the silver thing's not making me feel it
made me feel like it had the time all
right exactly but that novelty's worn
off now it's come and gone yeah it's
coming we need that gold and yeah
sometimes I said to people like oh like
I I have a plaque and they're like oh
that's cute which one yeah I've got like
four of those
yeah
yeah I I want the gold one
um so anyway guys
subscribe to the channel if you're
listening on any audio platforms please
leave a nice review follow the channel
help grow the cult and without any
further Ado guys it is time for top five
top five top five indeed right guys grab
your white boards grab your pens grab
your wipers so the top five of this week
is countries with the most people in
prison oh for God's sake countries with
the most people in prison where is their
crime
to be fair a lot of people a lot of
these countries have big populations but
they're out there they're lackluster
with their laws that prison system is
probably quite weak I just don't feel
like there's that many Indians in jail
I'm not gonna lie bro
I haven't been in India I haven't
written in India but you I know what you
mean it just all seem to be chilling so
I mean
I just don't feel like the better of
them are in jail because I'm in the
investigation process just doesn't seem
to bang like that
too many of them
investigation Mindy there's mind the
impressions are Bliss yeah super chill
people okay I'm locked right I don't
care about this one ram you're locked
and Ellis you're locked if you don't
care about this one James go first right
I'm a bit iffy about the last one
because they would we would never really
know I've gone USA Russia UK Brazil
and North Korea that's what I mean I
said we'll never really know they've
probably got 90 of the population in
prison but they're probably tell there's
like eight people in there uh REM yeah
I've gone USA
Russia
China
Mexico and Panama
I was thinking Mexico and Alice the
Menace
that name's really sticking Now isn't it
it is
um yeah so I did USA Mexico UK Spain and
China
right just to recap James he said USA
Russia UK Brazil North Korea Ram you
said USA Russia China Mexico Panama
Ellis you said USA Mexico Spain China
and the UK
right top 10.
number 10 Iran
okay 189 000 people in jail
number nine
Mexico Oh 220.1
000 people in jail number eight
Indonesia I was yeah 266
000.
number seven
turkey oh damn 291
000 people in jail Midnight Express is
about turkey
um it's a really really good prison
movie also yeah it's about a guy who
tries to smuggle
I think heroin back
from Turkey to America gets caught they
lock him up immediately oh God it's
scary God it's he loses his mind oh I
bet he does they have to transfer him to
a mental institute oh God he loses his
mind in there say less good movie
um number six
Thailand oh fair enough 309
000 people in jail number five
Russia okay
471 and a half thousand people in
Germany Russia Russia oh at least he
didn't put Russia unfortunately number
four
which nobody put
with a resounding 478 and a half
thousand people in jail India
turns out bro India for God's sake
that's what I'm saying about population
it doesn't make sense
enough bro India
number three didn't write China reverse
definitely in there with 811 000
Brazil gang
dang shout outs to the favelas so right
now James has two REM has one
and it has none number two if 1.7
million China China
knew it
did you put China yeah yeah
go on number one number one with two
points over two million USA
so we tied three three and three so it's
three and three yeah God's sake why
didn't I just put china bar I would have
won India is so big India's big Indian
Bridge what do we do I'm trying to think
what do we do now you've been uh you've
done the top ten you have to go 11 down
right what are we missing what's one
that what's what's the other two the my
other two yeah
um
China and no sorry China was there I
have uh oh you got Mexico and Panama
Mexico is in the top ten
but yeah
okay so REM wins Mexico is nine so REM
wins yeah yeah all right guys yeah there
you go I didn't care about that one so
it's fine
yeah you did care about it really yeah
okay that was top five guys so if you
got them at home as well right guys
let's take a very very quick break to
chat about our friends over at manscapes
where I was so friends family loved ones
I bet you haven't purchased the Father's
Day gift yet have you the answer is
obviously not because who would do that
no one cares about Father's day but you
need to stop bro because the dads out
there are important so not to fear the
leaders in below the waist grooming are
here let's go I'm talking about our
friends at manscaped they're saving the
day yet again with the total package for
the Father Figure in your life this year
it's time to upgrade his game from waist
to face with the exclusive offer have
him join the 8 million men worldwide who
trust manscapes and get 20 off plus free
shipping here it comes with the code
sng Sierra November golf
manscaped.com let's get back to the
episode all right cool so
real quick I want to talk about the show
the show the show
succession what a show indeed what a
flipping show indeed bro just as a
concept I didn't want to get into it too
much in terms of like episodes or
anything like that because I'm I'm on
season two mid season two same you're
mid-season two yeah and this has just
started right
um You Ever slide
um you first of all you hate TV you
don't watch anything I don't hate TV I
don't hate TV I just
that's where my time goes if I'm gonna
watch something it's it's very rarely
the the series that you guys suggest
Netflix
um whatever Disney plus it's normally
let me just spend that time on anime
that's what I do fair enough but I need
to jump on succession's unreal yeah if
you like money yeah and Scandal power
and
Powerful dark power Logan Roy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he doesn't lose he
doesn't lose he doesn't take else bro
um Netflix
yeah HBO maybe
um bro succession guys if you're not on
succession I'm here in obviously season
four is where the party's at yeah yeah
that's where the episodes are tended
yeah yeah but these episodes I'm
watching our juicy so basically all I
wanted to say about this show is that
after watching
that and getting invested in the
characters in The Plot yeah and just
like just the the chaos of it I'm a
money man now I'm a money man now so
from now on guys
just acknowledge me as a money man okay
and I'm powerful
I'm a money man that is a money man now
and he's powerful so
from now on that is in the business of
hostile takeovers yeah and big boy
Acquisitions now I can't afford
to buy out like BP Oil yeah or a hostile
takeover of Netflix
but your mum's chippy yeah
yeah
the local fan I got that yeah yeah yeah
your news agents yeah your Auntie's
newsagents I'm coming for you yeah I got
that yeah if you're if you're holding
out on me with a young dry cleaner I
expect to hear it you're gonna get a
call from my people we're gonna talk
money yeah I'm taking over yeah
succession is it's incredible man um
good show
Goods I like how all the characters in
the family
have their own problems and issues and
identities and stuff is and it all
Blends well it all Blends well Roman's
character is it's something he's Elm
your rock he's in a dark place you
already know his childhood was horrible
yeah horrible yeah they made jokes and
he's like nah that can't be true yeah
yeah that can't be true facts bro like
he comes in and jokes and lies about
everything as soon as someone jokes
about him he loses his call mind let's
tell the truth loses his mind is that
what that said tell the truth you're
talking about the the Stag day for
um shiv's man season I think it's like
late season one yeah I remember I
remember I remember remember facts bro
oh my God it's like they tied me in a
Cajun ship yeah the dog food yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro he had a horrible
childhood so yeah bro everyone's
character is interesting in the way you
start to love and hate each character
each time yeah like I'm on a bit I can't
stand [__] for the minute why why are
you up to just you can tell me what we
got to season two episode seven I'm up
to where copyrights Alice
um I'm up to the bit where she uh so a
couple episodes ago she baited they were
at the table with the pieces oh okay so
you're ahead of me then I think I've
Just Seen maybe the end of the episode
or the next episode after that okay cool
so you've seen where she baited she's
baited yeah yeah and the dad was not
feeling it he said he said let's go yeah
at the end literally let's go
um so like she's too she's hungry for it
and she's like she's letting that like
go to her head yeah yeah I know I can
see it now because when she said oh for
[__] sake that just tell them it's me
facts who are you to say who do you
think you are we agreed bro this is an
amazing new conversation you knew you
knew for a fact you weren't supposed to
run your mouth you know foreign
that state she thinks she's in the state
of her open relationship when she's not
full control she thinks she's got full
control of the whole thing
yeah yeah Tom needs to put his finger
out as well
he just wants power oh my money won't
stay he can't handle it he can't he
can't handle it but he definitely can't
handle that family because he's a [__]
amongst them but he tries to do top dog
with is it Gregory yeah Greg yeah even
Greg runs him about he does he secretly
Greg's my favorite character
favorite character on the whole thing
when he was blackmailing Tom yeah
I got the papers bro he's like hey we're
ready
I was like yes Greg let's go bro yeah
Greg's the guy um but yeah succession
bro it's got me in a new mindset yeah I
want to make money facts bro bro I want
to make money money money wins money
wins bro money wins bro when he got that
call yeah it's less [__] go screaming
when he didn't get it he broke the
helicopter yeah
you man just know your boy wants money
now money wins man so yeah if you see me
start doing just like public speaking
events
wearing a suit and tie just know I'm on
a money thing now money wins yeah yeah
if I start making a separate YouTube
channel just talking about real estate
money wins money wins bro I don't know
what I'm talking about but it's all
about it's all mindset yeah it's all
about the paper it's all about a money
mindset that's why I'm on right now
because succession has got me yeah cast
about Pete yeah these amount of stuff
yeah yes they've got stuff yeah yeah
they've got someone waiting at the door
to just take your coat and hats every
day
that's crazy it's nuts bro so yes this
actually is my addiction right now I
wonder if billions is anything similar
I've watched the first season of
billions it's not similar okay no it's
not similar it's like um
billions is a shh [__] version of
succession okay and I enjoyed billions
the system is succession is my obsession
okay I can't stop yeah yeah it's the
first thing I I every morning this week
I've opened my laptop and press play oh
man every night I've fallen asleep to an
episode oh man say less
I trust me again oh you do because
you're in it I'm involved oh I love it
it's a great show I love it I don't want
to watch anything else facts I don't
want to watch anything else
yeah yeah yeah I've had demons layer
just collating episodes I can't stop the
succession what was the last thing you
watching even the same thing as last
time oh man I'm like four episodes
behind I don't care okay session that's
all I want I want the Scandal yeah yeah
I love it it's really good man I love it
I haven't enjoyed the show this much in
God knows how long I love it same bro I
feel like I feel like how I felt when I
was watching like uh prison break and
Breaking Bad and then what kind of
things but I can't get enough of it it's
all I want to watch morning evening and
night yeah yeah oh my God I'm sorry guys
I just I just love it so much long story
short guys watch succession or start
succession if you haven't yeah and the
juice and everyone's saying that it
doesn't even get good till Seasons
before yeah and it's great now oh God
I'm intrigued for what season Four's got
to be same all these 10 out of 10
episodes I'm intrigued to see same yeah
right you've got a question for everyone
right I do have a question for everyone
um James obviously you answer first and
I will spin it around to the team so the
question is how long do you think you
can last if you weren't able to see your
reflection on anything
before I have like a psychotic breakdown
or kill myself or something whatever
how long would I last without ever
seeing my reflection not on a phone on a
mirror on water nothing man to man you
know you will never be able to well you
can't see yourself again
I'll probably flourish
okay
haunts me
I'm playing
um
I think I would I think to be fair
though I actually do think I would
flourish okay I think I would be in a
dark hole of paranoia yeah for like a
few weeks and I think I can't I can't do
this anymore yeah and then I'll be
second guessing why everyone's looking
at me what you're looking at yeah I
don't even know what my hair is saying
yeah I don't know what it's saying this
is what I'm talking about my Bob is
doing what he wants this is what I'm
talking about okay say let's say let's
defend it properly but then after after
yeah a couple months I think I would
mellow out yeah and I'd be like this is
the best thing that's ever happened to
me it's like if I just never went on
Instagram ever again I'd be I'll be
[__] yeah for the first few I don't
know what's going on in the world oh
Tick Tock no nothing no social media for
I'll have the shakes for a while then
after a few months I'm like well this is
the best thing ever I Feel clean but
yeah um if we're talking
for the sake of entertainment value yeah
the first few weeks I'll be I'll be
really really dark okay I'd assume
there's this nut on my face or something
there's always stuff in my teeth my
barber's done a Madness and everyone's
laughing yeah yeah everyone's laughing
but me you can't move to anyone oh you
can't move to anyone and if word gets
out that I can't see my reflection
people are just playing pranks on me
because I'll be talking and you'll just
be like that
yeah right
that's mad that's actually dread
yeah how long do you how long were you
last I'd probably give it a wholesome
couple weeks maybe two yeah I have to
see yeah because
I just don't think I can be able to I
don't know I feel like I feel like my
anxiety would be through the roof of
course it would even just going like
Sainsbury's would piss me off oh God no
exactly exactly yeah so my anxiety will
be through the [__] roof and it's one
of them ones where like you said
you could be walking on the street
walking down the road mind your own
business music in your ear having the
time of your life you could just be a
friendly person walking down the street
and you just do a smile and say hit like
a like a hello smile and then some
they're just looking like raw
them them backtrack Razzy like
what yeah facts like what what's going
on tell me yeah facts and yeah I don't
think I can handle it bro maybe two
weeks Max what about you rem I'm vain as
[__] I'm crumbling that album bro I'm
joking no I'm not no
um I think pretty much the same as what
what J Money said after a while
I would definitely shut down because
the anxiety will just drive me to the
ground and I'd be I'd be thinking I've
got a bogey there or there's a bit of
broccoli in my teeth no one's telling me
even though people can obviously see me
but I can't see myself
and obviously you just get used to doing
self-checks like you do yeah anyway you
do yeah a smell self-check every so
often if someone walks past you and it
smells stink you do a self check
to question whether there's something on
your face and not be able to just quick
check I'd be constantly doing this yeah
constantly you're back
starting to fall off my head just now
just now I saw it and no one told me
that's what I'm talking about bro make
it one week the bogeys would send me
yeah because like if you don't yeah and
if you can feel something there I think
I think it's hit oh no no no it could
just be hair yeah
and you just don't know and if not if no
one's there to tell you then yeah that's
just stress 100 I assume you don't love
me for me oh I assume that I don't trust
anyone moving you don't love me for me
wow okay serious Ellis I could do it for
I could do it for two days wow probably
two days I could do it for when that's
it no one would piss me off the most not
looking at my teeth and I was thinking
about brushing my teeth brushing my
teeth if I can't see I'm assuming it's
not clean yeah yeah tongue as well
I just assume there's always something
in my teeth yeah I think my tongue is
white white with bacteria even if I'm
brushing it I'm assuming it's white with
bacteria my eyes are yellow just cuz
everything's just you just see
everything for the worst yeah teeth are
nasty you'd assume that your eyes
instead of doing this just every day bro
everything hey would be in the ground
road yeah
bro you'd have a you yeah they think you
have Tourette's because you have a
routine down fat every like four minutes
you're black
fox fox fox fox no matter where I'm at
yeah yeah you're being a date like yeah
the thing is a glitch in a matrix yeah
bro oh my God crazy fair enough yeah um
right guys we're moving on to tweets of
the week obviously and I'm just gonna go
straight for it men come up with the
craziest Lies when they're cheating what
do you mean you're celebrating your
mom's birthday a month earlier because
she might pass away
reply facts because how are you killing
your mom's off to go [__] with your
girlfriend's cousin oh
oh reply oh you've seen the video too
yo that's jokes all right I've just got
one this one's sweet in me bro there's a
text combo yeah
why are you saying it funny related to
the episode okay why are you single
reply my boyfriend passed away five
months ago oh sorry reply it's fine
reply did you do it
the [__] what I was not expecting that
bro did you do it do it
raw fam wrong that funny enough I'm
twisted enough that if a girl takes me
that if they said why are you single my
girlfriend died five months ago she said
did you do it yeah that's the love of my
life
because you find out the fire yeah yeah
yeah funniest text of my life
we've got the same Banton
I'd find that the funniest thing I could
possibly receive did you do it
[Laughter]
right this is a tweet and a quote tweet
women really be gatekeeping their
friends quote tweet if I tell you I
showed you her picture she said ew would
you really be happy
oh
that's not even that's actually not
funny and I know for a fact it's true
the game is the game because Mandan
would just be like what's she saying why
are you being such product show me your
friend tell him to just just give her my
Instagram bro and she's like bro I gave
you Instagram agent because she's your
Butters men can't handle that of course
not I'm coming straight for your throat
you're a liar
look at me I'm bath stop that stop that
anyway oh God it's just a text
conversation
you hungry reply yes
all right cool eat before I pick you up
eat before I eat before I pick you up
I'm not made of money facts next one
sweet quote to eat most embarrassing sex
moment go
9 and 40 seconds shake my head she
didn't even know I just pulled out and
said nah you're not ready for this and
got dressed
foreign
[Music]
the privacy of our own Studio I've done
that before you have not I promise you I
promise you I've done it before bro I've
done it before
I don't know man I don't know
I've done the most bro this is okay
because I remember I remember where I
was who it was when it was okay I
remember I was terrified them ones yeah
yeah yeah
just log off yeah
log off and I was like right and she's
like oh please I just I know
I hate that one and I'm just in an
airline did you want it yeah
and I'm like are you sure you're sure at
the whole time my ass is here yeah yeah
you can't feel the same yeah you can't
know I'm soft my ass is 10 feet in the
air
and I'm just in there like you're not
ready you're not ready you're not ready
I'm ready
I'm ready you're not ready roll over
roll over yeah
[Applause]
I'll do anything come back bro I need
you right now
I don't know if you're gonna say how
real that is bro come on come on come on
come on come on I hate that you have to
do this I hate that yeah the rollover is
so clutch bro and you're just dead
you're spanking back you're spitting
you're just you're white please bro
please help me help me [__] that's so
funny wow
oh wow anyway back to it
former Elementary School teachers aide
accused of licking a boy's feet was
arrested again while he was out on bond
after he approached another boy and
asked to see his feet oh my God
oh my God bro enough is enough
wild I don't understand like
this level of urge you know what I mean
when you know it's so wrong yeah like
when people have crazy Kinks like they
need to like fap in public or they need
to like see kids feets or whatever it is
yeah it's like
fight it that's a king they clearly they
can't it's a compulsion they can't
like what's his face Roman and said he
can't fight it because Roman Roy can't
fight it yeah a Kendall can't fight that
coke he can't he can't he wants that
shoots that white girl who needs it oh
my days I got a few more tweets
uh gonna break into his house toast all
the bread and put it back
that's honestly the scariest thing I've
ever heard of mine I'm gonna break into
his house toast all the bread and put it
back in the bag bro bro can you imagine
I could never imagine pulling out bread
in its toast I'll pull him I'll be
thinking no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I live alone as
well
I will jump off my balcony I will jump
up my [__] balcony bro this is the
end of days that would patch yeah
there's nothing more to petrify me yeah
100 100 wow wrong because I think I'm in
flipping what's that clown name it yeah
yeah yeah I think I'm indenting I'm
going to turn around and see a red
balloon I promise
all my bread is toasted I'm turning
around there's gonna be a red balloon in
there and then for a fact oh my brother
oh Freddy Krueger's in there I'm in a
Dream Within A Dream oh my God
oh scream let me out wow wow all right
this one's a it's a picture this so this
is a reply from a from Summer story and
the chick is just in like a lingerating
hmm
and the man said come over I'll get you
pregnant reply I have an IUD
damn so you want me to drive there
that's a DUI
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's funny Bro [__] it up are you just
the implant yeah funny bro a few more am
I pretty
am I pretty
yeah why what's up you really think so
chill out I don't like lying twice
that's making my chest act up
oh I'm like shut up
funny last but not least tweeting a
quote tweet the love of my life is in
malta God how am I gonna survive this
week
quote sweet someone is gonna tilt her
head back and let that casamigos float
down her throat be safe my G oh
oh
that Casa Amigos flow down my throat I
couldn't read that tweet oh I would drop
bro that's the thing as well bro these
men let any brother pour juice in their
mouth
we're now out on a girl's trip yeah when
the drinks have been flowing and the
vibe is right I don't know how to act
the Bible's right in the Sun is setting
perfectly ah tonsils are on show Ah
that's it that's what matting as well is
that like
Amy Bray can hop off if you're in a if
you're in a dance any black girls won't
do this for the most part until they're
over the edge
I guarantee I can hop into any bar in
this country with a bottle of Gray Goose
and just start doing this will line that
up
they don't know who I am they don't know
what's in here
you can hop on any bars up and be like
ah yes
[Applause]
especially if I put it here yeah
yeah come on man yeah they're lining up
hold that
disgraceful stuff and a couple Mana
being there as well oh that's that's
embarrassing I was uh I was somewhere
okay and I'm not gonna lie I let I let
her yet pour it in my mouth I think it
was in
um
I think it was in Miami because I
couldn't afford a drink I don't remember
this we're in one bar it was a thundery
night that's all I remember remember the
day yeah yeah I remember when we ran to
the cafe to go and get pancakes with the
baked beans
baked beans baked beans yeah the banging
BBQ please yeah yeah bro I remember that
I remember that John Bro
yeah I think it was one of them nights
where it was it was stormy because the
club the club lights went out for a
minute oh man I don't remember this I
remember this all I remember the thing
that let us into the club was banging
standard
we had no money no prospects
and I couldn't afford a 40 drink yeah in
fact oh Miami was expensive well I
couldn't this is obviously for context
and we've told the story 100 times this
is like 12 years ago we were completely
flatbread this is pre money yeah yeah I
went out there with like 500 yeah
um
and one of the girls one of these bar
girls was pouring pouring shots in these
These Hoes mouth I lined up ah I I sat
on my tonsils bro Oh my days yeah she
pulled me something called apple sour
thing
and I just I remember this wife in my
mouth and just I was embarrassed I love
it it just looked hard
I went up and then came back to you and
Jacob saw me of course he did he did
everything he sees everything Jacob saw
me and said
is this what you're on I said I had to
get mines
I've got no choice these must yeah facts
needs I'm not gonna be in here sober and
I can't afford these drinks sucks I had
to hurry up say less ah but anyway guys
that's the episode for today yes this
was paying thank you very very much as
always patreon.com
run a piece of sng and let's have a good
time level of love
[Music]
foreign